le secrétaire d'état américain qui a
également rencontré son homologue jean
yves le drian hier les ministres des
affaires étrangères le ministre des
affaires étrangères français qui doit
être entendu en fin de journée à
l'assemblée nationale sur la sphère
justement des sous marins pour plus de
précisions justement on va retrouver
estelle farges notre reporter devant le
palais bourbon
[Musique]
bonjour estelle alors après le sénat la
semaine dernière jean yves le drian va
devoir s'expliquer à l'assemblée
nationale cette fois
et oui au ministre des affaires
étrangères est attendue ce mercredi à
17h30 devant la commission des affaires
étrangères une audition conjointe avec
la commission de la défense nationale et
des forces armées le ministre va donc
devoir elle s'expliquer sur la crise
diplomatique provoquée après à
l'annulation d'un contrat par
l'australie pour acheter à des sous
marins français
une audition qui intervient pendant une
semaine après celle du sénat mercredi
dernier jean yves le drian a été
interrogé par la commission à
sénatoriale des affaires étrangères les
sénateurs ont notamment tenté
d'identifier d'éventuelles défaillances
de la diplomatie et du renseignement
français personne n'avait identifié que
quelque chose se passait avait alors
assuré jean-yves le drian le ministre
qui a insisté la crise que nous
connaissons est grave et elle n'est pas
achevée simplement parce que le dialogue
est renoué et est ce qu'on en sait un
peu plus et celle sur la rencontre entre
antony green canet et emmanuel macron
hier soir à l'elysée
on m a égalé une rencontre tout en
sobriété pas d'image pas de
démonstration à d'amitié elle met un
long tête à tête entre le chef de l'état
et le secrétaire d'état américain
objectif restaurer chez la confiance
entre eux à les deux pays et préparer
des décisions concrètes
un entretien qualifié de positif et de
productif par un haut responsable
américain mais beaucoup de travail à
difficile reste à faire at il ajouté à
nos confrères de la fp une visite a
perçu comme une étape dans le processus
de consultation approfondie lancée par à
joe biden et emmanuel macron la semaine
dernière après leur entretien
téléphonique à qui a amorcé un certain
réchauffement
hier soir anthony blinken l'a reconnu à
chez nos confrères de france 2 on aurait
pu on aurait dû mieux faire au niveau de
la communication merci beaucoup et
estelle pour toutes ces précisions
estelle fages en direct devant
l'assemblée nationale à paris